Today I'm gonna make a steak and kidney pie,
but I couldn't find any kidneys,
so I'm gonna settle with just steak.
This is something I ate all the time growing up in England.
Even when I go home to visit, I'm.
I eat a lot of steak pies.
Steak and L pie, steak and kidney pie,
Guinness pie. They're all really good,
and it's just not something you can buy here in the US,
so I have to make it myself,
and it is pretty time consuming,
but it's well worth it. Here,
I made enough pie crust to make four pies.
If I just did tops or two pies.
If I did a bottom and a top,
then they reminded me about saving me pudding,
which is not a pudding, but it is a pudding
in a dish and put them in the oven,
and that kind of made me wanna do that, too,
but I need to calm down and just get this one done.
I have ADHD brain, so when I'm cooking something,
I'm constantly thinking about something else I can cook.
I put carrots in this and onions,
and I've used some bone broth that I made previously,
and then I rolled up the pie crust.
The pie crust was sitting in the fridge overnight
because I actually burnt the first pie filling
because I was trying to do gardening
and cooking pie filling at the same time.
It takes, like,
three hours to cook The pies filling to make it soft.
So in my ADHD brain, I was like,
I'm just gonna go outside and weed the garden.
And then I was out there for like,
45 minutes
and didn't realize that the pie filling was burning on the stove.
So we end up going to Texas Roadhouse,
which is just crazy, cause we never eat out,
but my husband's like, let's just go to Texas Roadhouse.
And then put two pie crust in the freezer,
and I put the one in the fridge.
And then I remade it the next day, and it was perfect.